[Music]
my name is Chad Jennings I'm a product
manager for bigquery and I've been one
of the Spear headers for the inclusion
of GIS inside of bigquery and so I am
like beyond delighted to be presenting
this story to you all this morning
partially because I think bigquery is
awesome person because I think gee I
asked you bigquery is awesome but more
because the story that we have to show
to you today is just absolutely worth
the next 42 minutes of your life
I should also a couple of public service
announcement the in the app please do
there's a Dory so we'll at the end we'll
be moderating questions the Dory
questions will come from the front mic
if there any folks with questions you
can use the rear mic but if you've got
questions go ahead and enter them as we
go we'll keep that Dory open for two
weeks after the talk so it's a place for
continued conversation all right well
that having been said let's go ahead and
launch so one of the reasons that Google
folks like to work at Google is making
the impossible possible as a mantra that
we have inside the company and and G is
inside of bigquery really exemplifies
that that capability we've we've been
able to unblock some very significant
workloads for customers as ondrea's Heim
from unicast shows here what we're doing
today or what an exciting announcement
that we're doing today is we're
announcing the general availability of
bigquery GIS so we launched the beta
back a few months ago and the adoption
has been absolutely stellar and with
general availability you actually get
quite a number of new features that
we'll get into in just a second
geospatial data it's interesting like if
you live in the Google world right web
logs are everything right because that
Google lives and breathes web web logs
but when you start talking about
particular industries especially talking
to people in those particular industries
geospatial data emerges as a critical
and blocker for very specific workloads
so across a number of these different
indices you know mentioned out here on
the slide
geospacial enables folks to get more
questions answered that just weren't
possible before we'll dive in in detail
in the public sector and IOT branches
but in addition to that like geospatial
data is also the cornerstone of pretty
much every ecological study ever done so
let me see if I can guide the mouse to
the right place here there we go
so what Greg Fisk is done who's a an
analyst at the Woods Hole Research
Center is he has plotted all of the ship
traffic in the circumpolar ship traffic
and so this video shows the rich
Recession the annual recession and
progression of the polar ice cap and the
blue and yellow tracks show ship traffic
here and one thing that Gregg noticed
through this is a the obvious one is
that every summer the ice cap recedes a
little bit further than it did the year
before and that the polar vessels are
able to traverse a little bit further
north the the Kenai to mug you as well
might have noticed some blue traces that
go right through the ice
those are ice breakers so you can do
that you can there's even one that there
it is it goes right to the North Pole
that's a $25,000 per person tourist ride
that you can get from novosibirsk just
in case you were wondering if that's an
option and so as they as they look at
these at these tracks they found that
the shipping traffic was moving further
and further north and the volume of the
shipping traffic was getting hires these
waters are getting easier to navigate
and so they're using that data to advise
policy makers for things like you know
how long should the hake fishing season
be how long should we be fishing for
halibut what should the transit
regulations be up in the north and
having bigquery GIS has enabled Greg to
do work that he wouldn't be able to do
otherwise all right
okay so what's new since the beta first
and foremost perhaps most importantly
and least excitingly the transition from
beta to GA means these features are now
fully backed by bigquery service level
agreement so they have the full weight
and force of Google cloud behind them
now that they're GA it goes a lot faster
than it did six months ago so I hope
you're all enjoying that we've also to
make it simply easier to use we've
expanded the number of files that we
import and a [ __ ] we've added a lot
more functions over the course of the
last six months by the way my favorite
here is the safe prefix this includes
other like not just geography functions
but other functions inside of bigquery
but if you do safe dot instead of that
query if it comes upon some invalid data
is in the course of running the query it
will actually not return and not fail
the query just returned null for that
particular moment so it's really handy
trick for debugging highly recommend it
and then kind of more fun here is we've
also added a geospatial support for
k-means clustering which launched
yesterday in BQ ml and so our Mickey
Mouse animation here shows that you can
now do clustering with ml on your
geospatial data that actually doesn't
happen in any other platform which i
think is awesome
and lastly bigquery geo viz which was
our very lightweight visualization
engine has now gotten a little bit more
heavyweight and we've increased the
amount of data that folks can visualize
by 25 X so get in and play with that
tool that'll be a lot of fun for folks
also supporting usage public datasets
there are an enormous number of publics
data sets that have geospatial
information in them so you don't even
have to bring your own data there's a
lot of interesting work to be done right
from these also the first the first
column here the rightmost one us
boundaries like if we go ahead and take
the trouble of importing the shapefile
to have all the county boundaries or the
state boundaries in the United States or
zip codes or census tracts right you get
the pattern here then you don't have to
worry about it
it's only just a joint away so bigquery
this is the the technology that we've
invented here between bigquery GIS and G
of is as I stated before is making the
impossible possible and when you put
technology in the hands of enormous Lea
creative and enormous least skilled
customers like a coma and geotab you get
some really amazing stuff and let me
tell you a very short story about how
amazing stuff lands today when it
started not quite a year ago so June
last year I called Mike who you'll meet
in just a moment and I said hey we're
launching don't tell anybody but we're
launching GIS and we're launching ml
inside of bigquery do you want to play
and Mike said oh that actually sounds
awesome seven weeks later geotab was on
stage here at next telling the world
about how these two technologies that
literally didn't exist in the public
think seven weeks before how they could
operate together so that level of
innovation was quite impressive so we
launched that in July last year round
about that same time Felipe Hoffa from
our developer relations team said you
know what a chlamydia tab y'all should
talk and they did and when you put folks
together who want to talk and want to
develop together they actually created
the system that I won't describe because
I don't want to give it away but they
created the system that we're gonna go
into detail here roughly simultaneously
with this Google sales kind of got wind
of this and said wow I can make this
like you know the tech Chad can do the
tech side but I can put this into the
hands of a lot of customers so thank you
very much and so we are here so anyway
they developed a go to market strategy
and we're actually here able to announce
the first deal where San Mateo County is
going to use the system that geotab in
Oklahoma have have developed so from
innovation through product development
through go to market to first deal
closed in ten months I think that's an
awesome story and now to tell you what
that story actually is Divya Herzl from
a Clemmie please
[Applause]
thank you so much Chad and thank you
everybody so air pollution is now a
global epidemic 92% of the world is
breathing unhealthy air that translates
to seven million premature deaths per
year which is greater than homicides and
traffic accidents combined and it's not
just you know these staggering numbers
as related to to mortality air pollution
is affecting quality of life for people
every single day and it's connected not
only to asthma and other forms of
respiratory disease but increasingly a
wide number of other human health
impacts like Alzheimer's diabetes and
it's even connected to higher incidences
of crime in cities and this is costing
us big money in the US alone air
pollution cost us eight hundred and
sixty six billion dollars last year and
to address this problem it really comes
down to a simple mantra and we have to
manage measure what we manage and manage
what we measure but current measuring
approaches are really insufficient to
address the scale of the problem it's
challenging to understand exactly where
emissions are coming from and who is
being affected with the current model of
measurement infrastructure that is
deployed across the United States but
also around the world that relies on
traditional methods of measurement and
that translate into very large equipment
that's not connected to the Internet is
difficult to deploy and so you end up
with a very sparse deployment of these
measurement sites across cities in the
city of San Francisco for example
there's one monitor for for the entire
city but in fact now thanks to work that
we've been doing for the last several
years which I will talk about it's
critical that we work towards a future
where we have
and information about emissions at a
hyperlocal scale and providing data that
is relevant and actionable so akima has
been working for the last 10 years to
really realize this vision of ubiquitous
air quality data and climate emissions
data so that we can really take action
at the local scale air pollution climate
change these are global issues but
solutions happen locally in our cities
and our counties in our state's in our
communities solving the challenge of
actually delivering block-by-block data
is an incredibly difficult technical and
scientific challenge and so akima has
invested nearly 10 years of R&D into
unlocking this capability we started in
2008 and have really reached a
monumental milestone in the last couple
of years with a very strong scientific
validation behind our methodology and
acceptance of our methodology broadly in
the scientific community which really
provides the basis for accelerated
global scaling we've been working with
Google since 2010 and so our partnership
with Google has been evolving over the
years and really excited about where we
are today we deliver a unified platform
so we're delivering best-in-class mobile
and stationary sensors I that really
worked to deliver the highest level of
possible level of data quality from
small-scale sensors we provide
end-to-end a network management so we
manage the entire network and all of the
data management and analytics on the
backend which runs on GCP and we make
all of that available in an
easy-to-access a SAS platform for our
customers to really empower our
customers to take action to reduce
emissions and reduce exposure and really
the core one of the core enablers of
city scale mapping is our proven
methodology that leverages connected
vehicles so we're really taking
advantage of the trends in in connected
vehicles to use
robing fleets of vehicles as a roving
sensor network and we've done some
really fantastic work over the last
several years with Google and Google
Streetview Google Earth outreach and a
number of scientific partners to
validate this methodology that results
in in representative maps of hyperlocal
hot spots and and and sources as well as
areas of exposure I mean so we're now
working with fleets and to scale our
data collection platform to scale the
mapping platform to deliver this data to
cities around the world and last year we
announced last September we announced
that we're taking our partnership with
Google and Google Streetview global
which is a really exciting development
in our journey with Google which were
incredibly just over the moon about and
to really bring this information again
to millions and billions of people
around the world you can actually see a
live demo of data streaming in from the
Street View fleet at the big table um
showcase and now we're working with
fleets other than beyond Street View and
other fleets um to expand our in scale
our efforts and which is why we're so
excited to be working with geotab one of
the leaders in fleet telematics so with
that Mike I'll hand over hand it over to
you
[Applause]
thank you so much divita just put this
mic down over here so first of all i'm
really excited to be here today to talk
about two really synergistic
technologies that i think together have
the power to really be transformative so
quickly about geotab we are the world's
second largest telematics company we
have about 35,000 different customers
across the globe right now and we are
available in commercial fleet so a fleet
might range in size from one to a
hundred thousand and typically these
commercial fleets use us for a few
different purposes so they'll use us
from a safety perspective from a
compliance perspective from a
Productivity perspective and we've got a
little device and it plugs into the
vehicle into the onboard diagnostic port
and it tracks everything from windshield
wiper activation through to engine rpm
through to harsh braking there's a
little accelerometer built in there and
we even got a gyro as well one of the
things that we've got on the port of the
of the little device is the ability to
connect up third-party sensors as well
so really transforms the commercial
vehicle into this IOT hub and all of
this data streams into the GCP platform
and what you're seeing here is really a
point cloud of a single day's worth of
driving of all the fleets that are
equipped with geotab vehicles and that's
one and a half million vehicles right
now across the globe and streaming in 30
billion data points on a daily basis so
we're doing that all through through GCP
so what's the problem we're trying to
solve for here right now this isn't the
traditional fleet manager problem but
it's a little bit different it's looking
at a fleet and how can I decide which
vehicles I'm gonna place these air
quality sensors on such that I can
leverage this amazing solution that
Ackland was created but it's not only
which vehicles to put it on it's which
fleets which fleets are best serviced
for this so in order to determine that
we've actually developed some really
cool machine learning algorithms that
take the driving patterns of vehicles
and transform them into different
vocations we've got 35,000 customers you
know garbage trucks police
couriers you name it so we have to first
understand how these vehicles are moving
around cities and once we were able to
do that we actually ran an interesting
study with the Environmental Defense
Fund which you can see through this link
over here and what we were trying to do
is figure out for specific geographic
area what are the types of fleets that
will best maximize maximize geographic
coverage and again it's all available
through that link but what this is
showing you here is a story for
Washington DC and we ran it with one of
our customers DC water at aggregate and
this is showing that over the period of
about six months we were able to get 70%
coverage of the entire geography of of
DC and that's using their public fleet
whereas you look at the private sector
fleets and you get about 50% and
although this is representative for DC
we were seeing this picture more or less
across the board for small large
municipalities and when we talk about
coverage it's really important to
understand what we mean when we say
coverage as well so we look at coverage
from a geohash perspective and for those
of you who aren't familiar with
geohashes it's a way of dividing up the
earth into various quadrants and we look
at it the geohash seven level which is
an alphanumeric representation of of a
specific area and we the geohash seven
level represents about five hundred feet
by five hundred feet and when we say
something is covered it means it's been
covered by about 15 different passes
through each of these geohashes okay and
that was again through the study with
with EDF turns out the having municipal
fleet vehicles collect these air quality
sensor readings is is a good thing it's
good because there's an incentive to
deploy there's a duty to serve back to
the public we have so many different
varied use cases of these vehicles to
you have public transit buses folks in
water and wastewater and the coverage is
so disparate that we get a really nice
geographic spread and then the third
thing is that there's always a link to
the environmental and sustainability
office so we typically work with the
fleet operations but you bring fleet
together with environment and you have a
really great solution here so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to give you an
example of a case say from DC water okay
and I will take Tim
fleet manager at DC water he's got about
600 different vehicles under his control
okay and he's been tasked with figuring
out which vehicles are gonna be best
suited for looking at integration of the
Ackland apply form which of his vehicles
he needs to put these on buddy I mean
he's already inundated with safety and
compliance and productivity issues he
needs a simple tool to be able to figure
out which of these vehicles that he
needs to put this on okay and you might
ask well why'd he just outfit the entire
fleet of 600 vehicles well first that
would be cost prohibitive and second of
all we've proven that he doesn't need to
do that he can do it on a smaller
segment of vehicles through
understanding their movement patterns
now imagine that you've got thousands of
Tim's we've got 35,000 customers
thousands in the municipal fleet sector
we need something that's going to scale
really really well we can't just do it
for Tim and expect to be done so I'm
gonna walk you through our process of
ingesting all this data transforming it
exploring it which is really important I
think the most exported important step
and then developing a solution that
works well a very very scalable approach
so I'm gonna flip back about two years
three years to 2016 where we were
monitoring 400,000 vehicles the old way
we looked at this so the vehicle will
communicate over the cellular network it
will send data through to our gateway
servers which sit on GCP that then goes
through to our streaming server again on
compute engine and through streaming to
to bigquery we're able to get that data
to bigquery within five to ten seconds
so for 400,000 vehicles from the time
the data hits our gateway servers at the
time it's available in bigquery is about
five to ten seconds problem is as we
started to approach a million vehicles
that really start to slow down so we've
got these dashboards across the board in
our entire organization that allow us to
see what's going on within our ecosystem
and we were seeing that five to ten
seconds jump up to 11 minutes 20 minutes
an hour I mean thank goodness we had the
foresight to look at to see this you
know coming about and we decided a new
approach was really needed and that a
new approach
what we're doing today so we've got
about one and a half million vehicles
again streaming through the cellular
network to our gateway servers of
segmented files are sent through to
cloud storage and then we've got
kubernetes engine that picks up all of
this day so we've got 36 different pods
in kubernetes that are picking up all
this data and then pushing it into into
bigquery using streaming inserts and
then we're able to maintain that 5 to 10
second lag so that worked exceptionally
well for us kubernetes gave us the
ability to scale really really well and
we can dynamically scale it up and down
as needed
so now that we've done the ingestion
time comes for transformation
so I mentioned we've got 30 billion
records coming in on a daily basis about
a third of that is GPS so 10 billion GPS
records now in order to develop this
tool that's gonna be really useful to be
able to figure out which vehicles we
want to deploy I don't need the RO
access to the raw data I need access to
some transform data so then we transform
this data the raw data comes in the form
of you know the vehicle the speed the
GPS we're getting every single entry so
10 billion of these entries coming in
then what we do is we throw it into
cloud Composer so essentially we we're
using a appache where you start off with
Apache airflow then move to composer
because it it's scaled really well and
then what we're doing is we're taking
the data from bigquery and essentially
putting it back into bigquery through
composer that works really well we use
this process a lot throughout the
organization and now we've transformed
it into a way where we've got the
metrics by geo hash and we can pull
those out directly from bigquery in the
application that we push out exploration
of data is absolutely crucial and
bigquery and BQ GIS have been phenomenal
for this for us so we've if anybody's
done any interpretation of GIS data as
scale you know it's difficult to put a
ton of data onto a map so what we've
done is we've developed a tool
leveraging deck GL that allows us to put
millions of points on a map and be able
to analyze that so I can throw a query
into this so this is the tool right here
into the side and then have it
visualized immediately and this is great
because all of a sudden my data
scientists who
have been running collab and Jupiter
notebooks now have the ability to write
a single query with geospatial context
and visualize it immediately all you
need to know is SQL which is which is
really really powerful and as a quick
example of what we did here during the
exploration process we literally mapped
all of the coverage within DC and we
decided it wouldn't be interesting to
take open data from DC and plot all
where all the schools are and see if we
can find an intersection of where if we
were to deploy these sensors where we
would be missing from a coverage
perspective on schools so we ran a quick
intersects the statement over here
leveraging SQL and it pulled out that
that data immediately so again a
leveraging bigquery bqg ass has been
transformational from a data exploration
perspective and we didn't stop there we
want to understand what kinds of
vehicles would elicit the best coverage
and ideally we've got vehicles that
would be electric or hybrid going across
the globe here too to do these readings
but turns out in many fleets that's
still a small percentage so if we were
to do it for DC water we get about
fourteen percent covered which isn't so
great we look at diesel you get about
forty four percent coverage gasps
fifty-nine percent coverage and if you
look at a consolidated approach you get
about 70 percent coverage okay so again
it does it does warrant the need to have
more of these hybrid and electric
vehicles I think within within
communities for us to be able to do some
really cool stuff so now that we
finished this as we've done ingestion we
did transform we did explore now it's
time to actually develop something okay
so what we've got a g8 have got a
marketplace not dissimilar to an app
store and I task our MVP team which is
our Minimum Viable Product team to
develop an application and this was
probably about a two to three week
initiative for them which was pretty
incredible and they were able to
leverage BQ GIS and develop a tool that
now could go up to our 35,000 different
customers to allow them to assess
whether or not they've got good coverage
and which vehicles they need to equip to
have some
to be able to integrate with a coma and
their two primary use cases that we
looked at
one was for citywide coverage so it's
looking at well what coverage can I get
from across my entire city am I missing
important areas and these important
areas could be augmented with data
available from a climate system as well
and more importantly as well to which
areas aren't covered are there important
school zones important areas that aren't
getting covered by this by this mapping
so what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
show you a quick demo here of the of the
application all right so what we're
looking at here is is the Adhan so we've
got the we've got DC's kind of
boundaries drawn here I'm gonna run just
a very quick analysis for you here so
it's gonna be from October through
December an aggregate level for DC water
and what it's doing in the back end and
I've staged if it's some data here
that's why it was so quick but we're
pulling off queries from bigquery
leveraging bqg ice as well and what this
is telling me here now is from October
to December I've got 55% coverage with
30 vehicles in this area vehicle eight
six one nine it's light duty truck it
represents about you know 81 percent of
that 55 percent coverage if i zoom in
here I'm able to quickly see each geo
hash and each geo hash that is
represented there means it's been
covered so at least 15 or more passes
the lighter the color the fewer vehicles
that were there so you can clearly see
the major arteries by the number of
vehicles that are just shown in a deeper
color in addition I've got this pretty
cool little chart over here that shows
my coverage percentage by number of
vehicles so if I have 30 vehicles which
I do 15 passage represents that 55% that
you were seeing up there if I scroll up
to here I get 50 vehicles I get about 61
percent coverage so I can look at by a
number of passes and and by number of
vehicles as well now let's say I want to
maybe look at this was for a three-month
time period maybe I can get some better
data and some better coverage if I look
at over six-month time period so if I do
that I jump up from you know 55 percent
to but
65% here which isn't isn't too bad what
I can also do is I can have a look at
filtering this date a little bit more so
I could do it by number of passes if I
want if I want to augment the vehicles
from 30 to 50 vehicles imply that filter
you can see that my percentage jumps up
to about 70 percent coverage as well so
it becomes a business decision at this
point in time as well is it worth
deploying another 20 vehicles for a 5%
increase maybe I can leverage some of
the data available from a Clements
platform to make up that difference as
well too so it gives you a good way to
explore which vehicles are going to be
the best to to give you coverage the
last thing I want to show you here was
that notion of looking at which vehicle
which areas aren't covered so we've
imported the again the public school
data from open DC and if I click this
tool icon here we're running that
intersects query over B QGIS and it's
looking for an intersection of areas
where schools aren't covered so I've
identified a handful of schools here
that wouldn't be covered if I were doing
that and if I looked at a major kind of
through fair here you know this is near
a freeway I could see that this
particular school here isn't immediately
covered its surrounding neighborhoods
are buts River terrorist education about
131 kids there that that wouldn't have
coverage so one potential is you might
put a stationary sensor there or again
it might be some data you could leverage
from a climate of a DES back on stage
here and she's gonna talk to us about
the amazing solution that the folks at a
clematis well
[Applause]
great thank you Mike so when it comes to
measuring air quality it's really
important to take a multi pollutant view
so that we can understand emissions and
pollution and a really granular level um
akima measures what matters when it
comes to air pollution emissions and
climate change emissions everything from
carbon dioxide and an ozone to black
carbon methane and particulate matter
we've been heavy users of GCP for the
past seven years and we actually started
using Google Google cloud tools before
Google cloud was a separate group and so
we've been really dedicated users of GCP
and during that time we built a lot of
custom infrastructure along the way but
we're really happy to announce that
we've now adopted GCP tools across our
stack from bigquery and cloud storage
cloud sequel kubernetes google iot
pub/sub and a whole breadth of of tools
from the GCP platform which has really
allowed us to focus on what akima does
best and we've in that process reduced
the complexity of our DevOps operation
and reduced costs by 65% and as heavy
users of bigquery and we're taking
advantage of the new GIS functions to
simplify complex querying and
aggregation to prepare for the
downstream analysis that occurs when we
ingest all of that data and then really
work to make sense help our customers
make sense of that data and we're also
really happy to announce today that we
are now a cloud SAS partner enabling us
to bring the best of everything that
aqua and Google have to offer to our
customers our services are offered
primarily through our SAS platform
through akima Pro akima Pro is a paid
premium service that allows public and
private sector customers in government
and the enterprise to access analyze
query a complex and dense air quality
and climate emissions datasets to better
and for
a wide range of decisions to reduce
emissions and improve air quality we
also have a premium service that we
offer to communities and to citizens
that turns all of that complex
information into data or all of that
complex data enter information that the
public can can consume in a really
intuitive way that enables broad public
awareness and engagement with air
quality in our communities the benefits
of that akima platform are broad there's
a broad range of capabilities that the
platform enables our customers empowers
our customers to do but fundamentally it
comes down to really being able to
diagnose problems at the city scale so I
often say that we're wearing creating a
wearable for for the city so that we can
actually diagnose what's happening why
it's happening identify hotspots and
sources reveal a spots for for human
exposure so that then we can actually
take action and and once we take action
understand the benefits of that action
understand the ROI on on the decisions
that we've taken as cities as as users
of the platform and so you know as an
example and I think one of the one of
the most powerful examples that that you
know we've seen again comes down to some
of our most impacted populations so when
you're a city and you have to make a
decision about where to invest public
funds to protect schoolchildren who are
often the most affected by pollution um
they're having to do that in the blind
sir without any data whatsoever but what
the platform enables our city users to
do is to target those funds in a way
that really targets those areas that are
most impacted and benefits the broadest
number of of citizens and children so
with that I'm very excited to pass this
over pass the mic over to John Walton
from San Mateo and and really excited to
be working with you John
[Applause]
good morning everybody I'm first just
let me say thank you all for coming and
I'm really honored to be part of this
group they invited me to come and talk a
little bit they are the type of smart
people I wanted to be when I went to
college and it turned out I wasn't smart
enough to be as successful as they were
so I went into government instead and
it's great to be here though I used to
be before I went to San Mateo County it
was actually the CIO here in San
Francisco for for about six years so
I've just moved one County closer to
where I lived down in Monterey when we
were putting this deck together they
asked me if I had the rights to all the
pictures because you know we all do
slideshows and people are asking me you
know can we show these pictures and I'm
happy to say we do have all the rights
and our kind of these pictures and
actually the the picture of the young
child is my son and so this is the first
time in my career and I've been doing
this for about 25 years
this kind of brought a lot of different
things in my life together which is why
I'm so excited to be here today so a
little bit about me and I know we don't
have a lot of time so I want to be brief
but I started out as a kid my big
passion is a child I want to be a forest
ranger I wanted to be in science that's
what I loved I love the environment it's
always been my passion and so that's
really when I started school that's what
I wanted to do I went to Humboldt State
University so if you ever been up to
Northern California you know it's a big
environmental area and that's why I went
there because was all about the
environment I was I had some very
idealistic views that I still hold today
by the way a lot of the groups we've
talked about environmental groups I
probably single-handedly kick-started a
lot of those when I was young and I
started when I started college I was
doing GIS a back then it was on a VAX I
was taking Landsat imagery I was doing
vegetation stress indexes trying to
figure out what to do I was mapping spot
all that spotted owl habitat marbled
murrelet habitat up in the north coast
and so I early early on in my in my life
and in my career I was convinced that
taking data and applying it good
and applying it in a way where you could
visualize it and get people to relate to
what was going on around them in a
personal level on a local level was
really what helped us make good
decisions as a community as a society
and drive change and so that was really
how I kind of started my whole journey
down this path of really believing that
so I got out of college I was going to
be an engineer but it turned out I
didn't really love calculus and fluid
dynamics so I I went more the natural
side and did a lot of hydrology and
things like that but I got out of
college and it was during the Reagan era
there was no jobs in the environmental
area goes go figure
and I got hired by a county because I
knew how to set up computers so that's
how I got into computers because I was
setting up all the computers in college
and really it took off from there so I
tell everybody if you want to be the CIO
of a government someday go to Humboldt
State you can actually sources planning
and you'll be set your your on the track
to be a world-famous CIO someday in
government but that fast-forward now 25
years later 25 years later to where we
are today you know in San Mateo County
if you think about our county you know
we're 800 square miles well 500 sorry
500 square miles about 800,000 people in
our county for those of you that aren't
from around here we're kind of the
Forgotten County between San Francisco
and San Mateo so our County actually
goes all the way from the southern
border of San Francisco which is about
50 square miles everything south of
there matter of fact San Francisco
airports in my County they pay us for an
INT which we love and goes all the way
down to Palo Alto we get the poor side
we get East Palo Alto they get stand for
down in Santa Clara but on the coast
side that goes all the way down almost
the Santa Cruz so we have a very diverse
County you know on on what we call the
Bayside the 101 corridor you know you
have 22 different cities all down that
corridor just amazing amount of urban
really dense probably a lot of you that
work here in the barrier probably your
CEOs or founders probably live in my
County Woodside Atherton Menlo Park
those are all in my County so you know
we have this very interesting very dense
very technically savvy engaged
population now if you go
over 280 if you've been down in our
County and you go to the Westside it's
all agriculture all mountainous all very
different now early on in the
presentation you saw a slide showing
where the sensory locations are if you
think it's challenging for San Francisco
which is 50 square miles so I have one
sensor in there County we're five
hundred square miles and I have one
sensor in my County and it's on the bay
side in Redwood City so if you live in
Half Moon Bay which is on the coast and
you're trying to understand what the air
quality's like in your neighborhood
based on a sensor in Redwood City you're
probably not going to see a really good
correlation between your real-world
experience and the stuff you're seeing
as the official air quality index so
that's how we got engaged here with
Google and acumen geotab cuz we were
convinced in the county that we needed
to engage partners like them to help
really understand what was going on with
our environment to make things better
for our communities at a local level so
we launched about a year ago now an
initiative in our County called SMC labs
government as some of you may know isn't
known for how fast we move so we created
this innovation group they engaged with
our partners we have signed an agreement
with them which we're very excited about
we see this is the way to really start
understanding given the fact we have 22
cities we have a huge fleet of vehicles
we manage you know over a thousand
vehicles for Public Safety for Public
Health
we manage Sam trans vehicles that do the
bus routes all over our County we think
this is a great opportunity to use a
combination of geotab and a clamed Atta
to really start understanding what's
going on in our county because you know
these problems we're trying to solve in
the real world they're not specific to
an invisible political boundary you know
the problems around air quality don't
stop when you crawl from one city to
another when they're all together
there's really a regional problem we're
trying to solve we're trying to engage
on all of us probably have loved ones or
people we care about in schools when we
when we head to fires
one of my other part-time jobs I'm a
trustee on a school board but when we
were having the fires up in the North
Bay that wasn't it just a North Bay
granted I mean that was horrific for the
people up in the North Bay but the huge
plume of smoke went offshore because of
the wind currents and came in over our
County and it was really eye-opening
just to see impactful that was to how
people perceived their quality of life
and things like that there was people
calling our hospitals sheltering in
place schools were closing I mean it
really caused sort of this ancillary
impact to the community to our our whole
region for a while that I think you know
you're always concerned about the people
who's losing their houses who's losing
their lives but it really brought home
to all of us how we're all in this
together and we have to solve these
problems together and air quality's just
I think one of those really easy to
understand important values that we can
look at that we can track and I think
you know my hope is in the coming months
as we continue to explore and expand
this partnership with Google and with a
Clemmie and geo tab and we start to
deploy more of this technology as we
start to do some of this analysis as we
create these great interactive maps and
visualizations that we can share with
politicians and the community about what
the current condition is in their
neighborhoods and what they can do in
policies and actions we can take based
on data that that's really gonna start
helping us make changes in our
communities here in the Bay Area and
then you know launch to other places I
know this is already going on we're just
in Denver last week at a smart cities
conference and they're talking about it
I think this is just really the tip of
the iceberg we're in the few years this
is just going to be the norm for
everything so I really appreciate you
all being here you're the brains behind
all this and I'm gonna hand it back over
to Chad
all righty so I wanted to first off
thank you all for for going with us on
the journey yeah that we've handed the
mic off a whole bunch of times in the
handbook for to presenting at this
conference they say not to do that but
really the story spanned a whole bunch
of organizations and a whole bunch of
use case and it was really important to
make sure to bring John on so that he
could explain like who the people are
that benefit from the maps that Mike and
divita are making so thank you very much
for coming
[Music]